all right let's get into audience
questions for the week first one is
about the 1.9 trillion dollar
coronavirus stimulus bill
uh dave and there's a bunch of versions
of this going around
uh but the question is why are all of
these right wingers saying
that most of the 1.9 trillion has
nothing to do with coronavirus
if it's a coronavirus relief bill now
this isn't true we're going to go
through
what is in this bill and actually uh
talk about
the origins of this claim that most of
the money isn't for coveted stimulus but
this is not a new claim from republicans
they did the exact same thing with
hurricane sandy
hurricane sandy when it hit new york and
new jersey
years ago i think it was 2012. the
response bill
contained not only money to fix
the damage that happened but also
because american infrastructure
is woefully outdated and because we have
an elected
a a system of elected government that
doesn't incentivize
thinking proactively spending now
to prevent a problem in the future that
will cause us to spend more money
we are in the unfortunate situation
where sometimes in order to get things
fixed and prevent future problems you
have to do it
when a system breaks and you have a a
problem
with hurricane sandy you saw that there
was
a bunch of money in the hurricane sandy
relief bill which people like ted cruz
referred to as pork and there was some
pork but a lot of it was
was not that meant to strengthen
infrastructure when you look at the
flooding that took place
when you look at the breakdown of all
sorts of different resources and
infrastructure at that time
the idea was hey we now have evidence
that because we didn't
strengthen this stuff because it's so
not robust it's so fragile
when we have a situation like a
hurricane that hits
an area that less frequently gets
hurricanes new york and new jersey
all this stuff breaks so as part of
recovering
let's also strengthen things for the
future okay with that
framework the meme that's been going
around is well hold on a second
if each american not everybody but most
americans
get 1400 bucks and then you get some
money for kids you'll see it floating
around that
only a few hundred billion of the 1.9
trillion
is for coveted this is so
silly but because it's being repeated so
much it's worth understanding
that in the 1.9 trillion you have
for example 160 billion for vaccine
purchases distribution injection
as well as covid testing that's covid
related
it's not cash for people but the more we
vaccinate
the the faster we do away with this
pandemic and the more the economy will
recover
come on guys you're saying that's not
actually for covid
360 billion for state and local
governments to make sure that
they are solvent solvent many states
because of the when you have a reduction
in business activity
states where those businesses exist take
in
reduced tax revenue the states
still hopefully are providing police
fire schools you know all this different
stuff so
as a result of coronavirus a bunch of
different states need money
you're really going to say that's not
coronavirus related
eight and a half billion for rural
hospitals to stay
open and of course those are going to be
important vaccination sites in rural
areas
25 billion to fund child care centers
it that you're going to say that has
nothing to do with coronavirus one of
the issues we have right now
is many parents can't get back to work
if their kids aren't back in school so
you very quickly start to understand
why funding child care which by the way
we don't fund enough in this country
anyway
is related to coronavirus 15 billion to
subsidize child care
for essential workers we need our
essential workers to be working
they need to be working to make money
but
if they have to be taking care of their
kids they can't work and then they can't
put food on their family's table this is
it's coronavirus related why are we in
this situation
130 billion for k-12 schools to reopen
and decrease class sizes
it costs money to decrease class sizes
to open safely
if you decrease class sizes you either
need additional teachers to have way
more classes
or you need to be paying overtime if
teachers are going to be doing two
sessions
however you're going to do it it's going
to cost money people
on the right want schools open people on
the left want schools open safely
here's money in order to do that we
could go on and on and on you know um
15 billion dollars to prevent airline
layoffs
okay there are some who are saying
airlines should be allowed to fail
unfortunately air fortunately or
unfortunately whatever the case may be
airlines are a big piece of
infrastructure transportation
infrastructure you could make the case
let them fail but we're going to be
depending on airlines
if and when things start to improve uh
to
um allow commerce and allow travel to
restart travel one of the hardest hit
industries so
you know you you can make a case on any
of these things well maybe the 15 should
be 12
or something like that but the the
talking point that's floating around
is most of the money has nothing to do
with coronavirus and of course that is
completely and totally untrue
this isn't a new talking point from the
right
and it's not at all surprising that
they're rehashing it and reviving it
right now